[Music]
what a sweet-ass run it's been
forces of darkness and bye
[Music]
[Applause]
we have the job that anyone else would
kill to have so when we go to work we
have a really good time I'd like to
explore the Falcon as a character what
kind of man is this man we'll find out
we don't want it to be all action all
the time I'll do my best
we need to go home with these characters
we need to spend time or really
unearthing who they are and since we've
got great actors put them in situations
where they really get to show what they
can do we can create the same exciting
high end action sequences but then in
between those set pieces we get to dive
deeper into the character piece so it's
the best of both worlds
I'll be seeing you very soon Daniel
Bruhl is returning as Baron Zemo from
Civil War Sharon Carter is returning
miss Emily VanCamp it's gonna be an epic
adventure I think and I'm so excited to
be here and a new character entering the
MCU in this series is a character named
John Walker and he's played by the great
Wyatt Russell gentlemen welcome back
everyone it's Charlie this is gonna be
my breakdown of the Marvel phase 4
trailer for falcon in winter soldiers
that they just dropped there's a whole
bunch of Marvel phase 4 stuff happening
this week so I will do footage for all
the different trailers that they dropped
over the next couple of days be sure to
subscribe to get everything we're also
still doing that Avengers infinity saga
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite Marvel phase 4 series that's
coming up on the video so they start
with Iron Man's voice over opening the
trailer
lots of voiceover from the original
Avengers introducing the Marvel phase 4
trailers the old guard classic
characters teeing up the new stuff
pretty standard tactic then you get the
transition to the full official Falcon
and Winter Soldier logo notice how they
rotate it and it starts with winter
soldiers classic Russian armed with the
red star but it extends into a shiny
metal version of Falcons wings because
it's both falcon and winter soldier
together teaming up the reason they
team-up will become clear in a second
when they introduce all the antagonists
Baron Zemo is technically the main
villain but there are a lot of other
people Falcon and Winter Soldier will be
fighting against from the US government
side of things Thunderbolt Ross's people
now the cap has officially retired and
passed the mantle and the shield on
Thunderbolt Ross feels like the shield
belongs to the US government so that's
gonna become a big problem for Falcon
and Winter Soldier during the series
they rotate the logo and it's made to
look like a version of the American flag
but they transpose Captain America's
shield where the stars would be because
cap has passed the shield in the mantle
to Falcon at the end of Avengers endgame
the only thing bumming me out is the
fact that they live in a world without
Captain America Oh
it reminds me
they actually explained after the movie
came out that Bucky here in this moment
before cap goes back in time to return
the stones and Thor's hammer to where
they took them from he knew exactly what
cap was going to do and that's why he
gives them that strange look of knowing
and says I'm gonna miss you buddy like
he knows that he's not coming right back
he's gonna go and live his life with
Peggy Carter and maybe he'll see him
again
but it'd be a vastly changed version of
him and before this moment here the
writers said that he and Bucky had
already had a really long talk about
what was going to happen and their life
together like they're sort of really
long goodbye that's why cap only has the
conversation with Falcon at the end of
the movie instead of having a long
conversation with Bucky plus if you're
mad they didn't get a moment together at
the end of the movie you have to imagine
that after this moment here it's implied
that they helped Captain America settle
down in their reality somewhere quiet in
case they ever needed his help again
but for all intents and purposes he's
retired and decide from flashbacks Kevin
Feige and Chris Evans haven't really
said anything about old cap coming back
for cameos during the Falcon and Winter
Soldier episodes but maybe there will be
a small old cap surprise then they talk
about the premise of the series what
happens to these two characters between
the Avengers movies when the Avengers
are off doing other things on their own
- they kind of gave you a preview of
that during Avengers infinity ward
there was a prelude comic book that
featured Captain America's Secret
Avengers they spent most of their time
between Captain America Civil War and
Avengers infinity war dismantling the
International aliens armed trade
remember spider-man homecoming the
vulture and the Tinker were selling
shatori weapons all over the New York
tri-state area caps Secret Avengers were
taking care of that on a much much
bigger scale they reintroduced Baron
Zemo as the main villain wearing his
comic-book purple mask finally his
rumored plot during the series will be
trying to release some crazy nerve gas
biological agent around the world and
Falcon and Winter Soldier had to stop
him then capture him enroute to getting
him ready for a thunderbolt series down
the road with Thunderbolt Ross
there were a bunch of reports last week
that thunderbolts had gone into
development officially but no date on
when they would release that series then
we get a look at their brand new
uniforms bucky looking like he's cleaned
up big-time and wearing a Captain
America variant of his Avengers infinity
war costume even more like the Captain
America costume that he's ever been
before they added the star back to his
vibranium arm but it's a white star for
America instead of the red Russian star
the Falcon suit is also interesting
because it's not as much like the
Captain America suit as I expected so in
the comics Falcon eventually takes the
mantle of Captain America but this is
what the suit that he wears looks like
when he does that the reddish looking
suit that he's wearing in this series
looks a lot more like the suit that
Falcon wears after he gives back the
mantle in the shield to Captain America
in the comics at least in the comics he
stopped being Captain America a couple
years ago and just went back to being
Falcon but Anthony Mackie actually did
say during an interview that he would
not be replacing Captain America during
this series this is the clip of him
talking about that Captain America so is
this is the title changing how does that
work no I'm the Falcon I will always be
the Falcon the moniker will stay the
same so hearing him say that and then
seeing that he's not wearing a Captain
America looking costume I think there's
a reason for that and it also involves
what's going on with Thunderbolt Ross
during the series so I'll explain that
in a second but he is wearing the
special straps the Captain America wore
to holster his shield on his back so he
will be using the shield during the
series Sharon Carter is coming back as
the main character she has a much more
hardcore suit just meaning she's gonna
see way more action this time she's
still working for the world Security
Council and Thunderbolt Ross
I'll explain her role in a second
because she's kind of stuck in the
middle between a couple different
factions the other new character is
actually pretty interesting John Walker
is his name he's also known as US agent
in the comics he's kind of one of the
other antagonists he's the new version
of Captain America that's on the
government in Thunderbolt Ross's payroll
the [ __ ] version of Captain America
that Thunderbolt Ross wants to be
Captain America we're starting to get
into Dark Avengers territory here so
I'll explain what's going on with that
too because that sort of gets into the
Thunderbolt series John
Walker in the comics wore the mantle of
Captain America for a brief period he
was a super hardcore Punisher esque
version of Captain America before Steve
Rogers took the mantle back what they're
basically saying is is a Thunderbolt
Ross in this series is not cool at all
with Falcon having the shield so you'll
probably see a battle for the shield
situation going on during the series if
you're a big Batman fan
remember battle for the cowl with a
bunch of Batman's people fighting for
the right to become the next Batman same
idea only with the mantle of Captain
America who has the right to be the next
Captain America is it the person that
Captain America wants to become the next
Captain America or is it Thunderbolt
Ross who technically owns the rights to
the shield remember Ironman at the end
of Captain America Civil War my father
made that shield it doesn't belong to
you
so all those questions will be answered
during the Falcon and Winter Soldier
series Sharon Carter is kind of caught
in the middle between those different
factions between the Thunderbolt Ross
people and between Falcon and Winter
Soldier in Baron Zemo because she's on
thunderbolt Ross's payroll but she's
also team cap so Falcon and Winter
Soldier are her friends and she's trying
to help them take down Baron Zemo while
also trying to keep Thunderbolt Ross
from messing everything up so if we're
talking about future Dark Avengers plans
or Thunderbolts series evil or dark
versions of the Avengers characters John
Walker would be their version of dark
Captain America on that team and if they
have problems using Norman Osborn to
lead a Dark Avengers team or a
Thunderbolts team early speculation
they'll probably wind up using a version
of Red Hulk Thunderbolt Ross or just
Thunderbolt Ross there's supposed to be
some kind of teaser for that during the
Black Widow movie so just be prepared
for Thunderbolts set up post-credit
scenes but post all your theories in the
comments below I've got a new black Adam
video that I'm working on that a
hopefully post later today while you
wait for everything click here for my
brand new Avengers what if trailer
breakdown and click here for my brand
new Star Wars the Mandalorian episode 1
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
you